Here's an example of extending our previous top level description with
some properties. We still have our client and server components.
We still have our RPC connector. We still have our attachments. However, we've
added some property statements within the descriptions of the components and
connector. In particular, the first property is labeled Aesop-style, and
it's some kind of style ID. Second one is Unicon-style. Now, be aware that Aesop
and Unicon are other architectural description languages with their own tools.
By the way, I've indicated here a comment using C++'s slash, slash commenting
style. For the second component, the server component, there are two properties,
and these are not intended for particular external architectural style
architectural description language. The first one is labeled idempotence, and
it's got a Boolean value indicated as true. The second one is an integer,
including a maximum concurrent clients that this particular component can,
is capable of dealing with. As far as the connector is concerned,
there are properties for synchronization. For the maximum number of
roles that that connector can have and for a particular protocol, in this case,
using the Wright, as in Frank Lloyd Wright, architectural description language.